hi in this video I will teach you how to
use image a in order to process can
focal microscopy data so you have our
data of confocal microscope a confocal
microscope image the conferral
microscope would give you a composite
image of all the channels and now for
representing it in a paper you have to
do a lot of processing you have to split
the channels so let's open one data so
here we will open one data one image of
confocal a composite image so here you
can see after clicking on the image and
open image would open so this is the
conferral image RGB image you can see it
saves RGB and it also gives the pixel
value of this particular image and now
what we would do would split the
channels and see what what is in green
and what is in red and then we would
give a March and we would place three
side-by-side for better understanding so
in order to perform this thing first we
have to get to image and then colors
there we have to change the option to
make composite so when we make it
composite now here you can see there are
three separate channels are there
combined each other our G and B you can
see in the header it's in blue then you
can see it's in green now you can see
it's in red and now we would go again to
image toolbar and then we would go to
color and then split channels when we
press the button split channels it would
split the channels so this is the
channel for black this is the channel
for blue and in our image is nothing
stained in blue color that is why we
don't have this particular thing so we
don't have to represent it just forget
about it then in green channel we have
something
and the red channel will have something
and probably these are neurons and these
are some particular protein stained with
a particular antibody and now we have
one to represent this thing first this
image then this particular image and
after that we want to represent a large
image of these two then we have to do
what one thing you have to open again
the image now we have three particular
image and we want to use now what we
would do we would go again image and
stack option and in a stack option we
would say a press image to stack so it
would stack all these images and when
you press ok so after pressing ok you
would see all our three images are now
stacked on each other first we have the
red one R then we have the green one we
don't have the beach angle because we
deleted the channel and now we have the
composite one and then what we would do
we would represent it side by side and
in equal ratios so that one could
understand in much better way so in
order to do that would again go to the
image toolbar then we would go to stacks
and there is option for make montage to
click that option make montage and it
would ask you a lot of questions first
column 3 yeah we want to make it one row
and three columns and we would change
the scale factor usually scale factor
denotes the quality then there are other
sizes then font size font size you can
set and ok and then we have to click on
OK
we click on OK it would take some time
as you can see the image is processed
over here and now you can see side by
side all the 3 images so here all the 3
images were stacked and for
representation in paper
here all the image is in a montage
format where we you have first a red
channel then our green channel then to
channel mixed up in a composite it will
be merged then we will level these each
panels for better understanding I hope
this video helped you if you liked my
video give it a quick thumbs up don't
forget to subscribe and share and leave
your comments below
thank you